Hi guys.
Dr. Berg here.
In this short video, we're going to talk about
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease.
So many people have a fatty liver and it's
not really coming from drinking too much alcohol.
There's other reasons for that.
The main reason is insulin resistance.
I'm going to explain that.
If you haven't seen the other videos, I'll
put some links down below.
But this is very important.
See, insulin is a hormone that helps regulate
blood sugars.
A lot of people associate it with diabetes,
but insulin is the hormone that if, even in
a small amount, it converts food, especially
carbohydrates, to cholesterol and fat.
It really loads up that liver with fat.
So in the presence of a little too much insulin,
you're going to get a fatty liver.
It may not even show up as a weight problem
at first, but it will probably show up in
the mid section as far as a fatty gut.
This is just my opinion, I think because I've
tested it so many times, I've sent people
to the radiologist to get ultrasounds on their
liver.
If you take someone with a gut, they have
a fatty liver.
A lot of times, when the liver fills up with
fat, it spills over into the gut and you have
this roll around the top section or you have
this protruded belly, which is a whole other
thing.
Here's what happens.
The problem with this fatty liver is that
you don't really have any symptoms for a long
time.
The liver has to be almost completely destroyed,
like 90%, before it even shows up on blood
test.
So you don't even know you have it and it
doesn't create any problem until later in
life when you're surprised.
I'm just bringing your awareness up.
Because what's happening at the cellular level
is turning into cirrhosis, that scar tissue.
The liver's becoming like fibrotic and so
it's going to lose function over time.
It might show up in arthritis and joint problems
and fatigue, but it might not at first.
The point is that you need just to be aware
of this is a serious problem down the road.
So, you've got the cirrhosis, this liver roll,
and what's happening is the body is releasing
insulin.
Insulin resistance is when the insulin is
no longer being accepted like it should in
the liver.
So the liver is blocking it, it's resisting
it.
The signal goes back to the pancreas and says,
"Hey, it's being blocked, it's not going in.
I can't hear you."
So then the pancreas starts producing more
including because the return message is the
feedback is not connecting.
It's kind of like talking to your child telling
them to take out the garbage, they're not
listening.
You're going to increase the volume, start
shouting at them.
That's what's happening right here.
We have this five to seven times more insulin
pumped up by the pancreas than normal people.
What's going to happen is it's going to create
a huge problem with the liver.
It's going to start getting fattier and fattier
and fattier.
I remember this in my patient.
This one guy came in.
He had 95% of his liver was completely filled
with fat.
I remember as I'm looking at his abdomen was
all distended and sticking out and he was
doing ice cream every single night.
I know you're not doing that.
You probably know people who do that, but
if you've been watching my videos, your diet's
probably absolutely perfect right now.
Here's some solutions to correct this.
First of all, you have to know the liver is
one of the only organs that can take a real
big beating and regenerate 100%.
Liver tissue can come back.
That's the good news.
The bad news is it takes a big of time.
It could take up to three years of eating
healthy to restore your liver.
You can't just do it for two weeks.
Now, one of the best remedies that dissolves
fat is choline and you can buy this from the
health food store, choline.
It's considered a type of B vitamin, but it's
really lipotrophic, which helps dissolves
fat in the liver.
Probably whatever it's recommending I would
triple the dosage.
Start taking that on a regular basis.
Again, I don't want you to get the impression
that it's just taking a pill to fix your liver.
You have to fix your whole lifestyle.
You have to fix your eating.
You have to take a whole body approach because
it's not going to work just to take a pill
and not change your ways.
Cruciferous vegetables are the other thing
that you need to start consuming, because
that will also help fat out the liver.
If you want something to enhance it, you can
do something like this.
This is the organic cruciferous concentrate
and you take this.
You would probably take nine to 12 of these
a day if you have a fatty liver to help support
the liver to help clean it up.
So that's another thing you can do to enhance
your diet.
You cannot fix this without actually eating
tremendous amounts of vegetables.
If you don't like vegetables, you're going
to have to start eating them somehow.
Maybe in a shake or something.
It's almost impossible to fix this condition
if you don't consume vegetables.
These other things are just enhancements.
They're not the cure.
The other thing is you don't want to consume
any sugar, because the sugar activates the
insulin.
We want to avoid the sugar, the hidden sugars.
Add more vegetables.
Choline is a really good one.
Cruciferous is another one.
Again, it's not as easy as doing these.
There's other complications.
You have individual specific problems.
If you really are serious about getting healthy,
you maybe want to consider signing up for
my membership site.
In that site, you have me to guide you.
It is do it yourself, but you can always ask
me a personal question.
It's probably the most cost effective way
to get help, because I have over 200 lessons
that you would learn from.
I put a link down below so you can check it
out.
You've got a month to test it out to see if
you like it or you can get a refund.
It's a great program because you get all the
details of what to eat, what not to eat, what
to do as far as techniques, remedies, things
like that.
Then, you can ask questions and have me as
your guide.
This is a really good thing to take the holistic
approach and to give you the knowledge, so
you're not at the effect of these conditions
just because you're missing some information.
I like to give you the whole scoop, help you
understand it.
Go ahead and apply some of these tips right
here and I hope this educated a little bit.
Your next step is to get started.